from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between dominoes in india and the us
this is food wars
here in india our domino's pizzas come
in three sizes our domino's pizza comes
in four sizes the small eight inches
with four slices the small ten inch
which is six slices
the medium 10 inches with six slices the
medium 12 inches which is eight slices
and the large 12 inches with eight
slices
the large 14 inch which is i don't know
four eight nine ten
16 slices because i don't know why they
cut it this way i didn't ask them to so
and the extra large 16 inches or six
slices
unfortunately our large margherita pizza
only comes in one crust option which is
the hand tossed you don't get it in pan
or in cheese burst or any other kind so
i am going to weigh one slice of large
margarita hand tossed pizza to see how
much it weighs
93 grams and i will weigh a slice of our
hand tossed and our pan to compare the
weight please note that our mediums
are the same size as their larges
that's pretty insane
yeah i'm not surprised by that at all
buddy hand tossed one
random slice is 79 grams a
slice
a pan
same
surface size we'll say but obviously a
lot thicker like wait i mean come on
139 grams so that's a little less than
double
this is a large domino's margherita
pizza it's also known as the plain or
cheese in the u.s this is 12 inches long
it costs 419 rupees or 5.55 us dollars
at current conversion rates so the total
surface area of this pizza is
729.7 centimeters square which means it
costs 0.76 cents per square centimeter
of this pizza take our large 14 inch
pizza which is 13.99 or 1056 indian
rupee with an area of 993
squared centimeters just like these
slices are squared i totally did that on
purpose that's 1.4 cents per square
centimeter that means the indian pizza
is 45
cheaper than the american version
this is everything you'll get on a menu
at domino's india that you will not get
in america
a little skyscrapers you guys have
actual skyscrapers we have domino's
pizza box skyscrapers here's everything
at the us dominoes you can't get in
india we have five it's done we have
five different crust options we have pan
then you have
wheat thin crust
cheese burst
is there supposed to be cheese in here
oh
[Music]
there is cheese in here for sure
then we have hand tossed and we have
something called new hand tossed maybe
somebody else's hands were used to make
this one in the u.s our domino's has
five crust options this one right here
gluten free but you can only get that as
a small pizza next over here hand tossed
over here the much thicker pan that's
medium only this guy in the middle here
is the crunchy thin which i just found
out five seconds ago they also cut in
squares didn't know that last and
certainly not least this is the brooklyn
style they're thin slices but you only
get this in the large and the extra
large hell yeah that looks so good just
by looking at them i can tell that the
hand tossed
is slightly thinner
new hand tossed
it's a little firmer as a crust i would
opt for the regular hand toss pizza
finally just for fun the cheese burst
that is such a guilty pleasure so i
thought this was cheese burst in the
sense that just the outer ring of crust
had cheese the entire pizza base
is cheese burst all right here is our
range of vegetarian pizzas here in india
to keep with the religious sentiments of
both hindus and muslims who are a
majority in our country we avoid using
beef and pork in most fast food
restaurants but what that means is that
we get a lot of delicious you know
vegetarian options number one mexican
green wave i will say the colors on this
pizza definitely look like the mexican
flag jalapenos some tomatoes onion
cheese next up we have veggie paradise
wow
imagine calling an entire pizza of
paradise red peppers capsicum olives
corn and cheese you guys in the comments
let me know does this look like paradise
to you i'm not in the comments but i'll
tell you right now it absolutely does
not it's funny
their veggie paradise is my pizza hell
next up deluxe veggie mushrooms paneer
corn capsicum and onion
[Music]
i typically don't like when there's too
much on my pizza but the things here
really complement each other pretty good
but again there's so much going on in
this it's truly a deluxe pizza next up
we have peppy paneer how fun red peppers
capsicum
and paneer if you are wondering what
paneer is it's basically cottage cheese
and we
love
our paneer okay next up we have paneer
makhani if you're wondering what makhani
means it's a paneer version of butter
chicken if you're wondering what butter
chicken is friend you need a culinary
education
[Music]
would i ever want paneer makhani on a
pizza maybe not i don't like it next up
we have cheese and corn it's got cheese
got corn
and finally indi
paneer tandoori pizza tandoor is
basically an oven we use here it's
cylindrical we use wood fire and coal in
it to sort of give the meat and bread
some chaat to it and indi well this
pizza has just not hit mainstream yet
oh that is
spicy and a half if you can't take heat
avoid this one my favorite so far none
of them i will order a non-veg pizza wow
india has a lot more vegetarian options
than we do and good for them i
personally don't want any of that we do
have two of our own exclusive veggie
options this here is the pacific veggie
and over here we have the spinach and
feta i don't want to try either of these
do i have to
it's a wasting valuable stomach space
you know like it's only so big all this
awesome domino's food here you think i
want any of this in my stomach who cares
all right fine
what's it like feta cheese on it this
isn't so bad
non-vegetarian pizzas number one we have
the pepper barbecue doesn't look like it
has any vegetables just a bunch of
chicken pieces and
with a nice smoky barbecue flavor but
you can choose a pepper barbecue chicken
with onion
that is a great combination
chicken sausage quite quite sausagey for
sure the next pizza is what i believe to
be the best pizza you can order from
domino's india the chicken golden
delight what a delightful name this is
one of the oldest pizzas that's been
there on the domino's india menu it's
got nice sweet corn it's got some
jalapenos in there and some delicious
delightful chicken
next we have the dominator which seems
to have
every single meat topping option on the
menu
my god
consider me dominated i don't think i
don't think he knows what that means
wow we're learning a lot about nikhil
today aren't we
whatever you do my man and next we have
chicken fiesta it's got some tandoori
chicken pieces some capsicum onion nice
simple flavors you can't go wrong with
this one and finally indie chicken tikka
which is just the chicken version of
that paneer pizza i had and that one
just burnt my lips so steer clear of
this one if you can't handle spice but
if you do
this is the one you should get actually
some of those look pretty good i'm very
impressed now here in the u.s
every pizza that has beef on it is an
exclusive and we also got some chicken
ones let's do this i am starving all the
way over here this is the
extravaganza
which looks to have a bunch of veggies
mushrooms and pepperoni
thank you
yeah
this is the meatzza two capital z's i'm
seeing pepperoni ham sausage possibly
hamburger all the meats hell yeah let's
go
[Music]
um i can maybe do one bite of that we're
next turn a sweat next we got the
hawaiian pizza
mmm
a plus on this one
definitely very good cali chicken bacon
ranch you see it looks like it has uh
sun-dried tomatoes bacon i'm assuming
and chicken white sauce little flimsy
guys this is the brooklyn style so i
don't know why it's california
oh yeah
no white soft buffalo chicken pizza i
mean they drizzled it on there right you
see that just drizzled
this one's like surprisingly very good
the ultimate pepperoni not just any
pepperoni pizza the ultimate pepperoni
oh yeah well it's covered in pepperoni
who is right
oh yeah put me in a pepperoni coma
oh yeah oh the deluxe deluxe is just
that a little bit everything black
olives sausage peppers ham probably
bacon
you put black olives on anything it just
tastes like black olives ooh memphis bbq
i am pro barbecue sauce on pizza it
looks like a chicken here too yeah
onions
mmm
yeah
oh man that barbecue sauce that's really
nice wisconsin
six cheese there's no way there's six
cheeses here i don't think i can name
six cheeses we have mozzarella cheddar
asiago is american that kind of cheese
did i say cheddar yet
blue i don't know
next up if all of those non-veg pizzas
aren't enough for you they have an
entire section called chicken lovers and
they have these four pizzas that look
absolutely insane they're more topping
than pizza at this point this one is
called the chicken five feast so they
have chicken pepperoni chicken tikka
chicken meatballs
there is so much going on over there i
like it but it feels like a drug a pizza
drug
next up we have the spicy double chicken
it has two different types of chicken
pepper chicken and tandoori chicken and
i assume it would be spicy and i'm gonna
take domino's word for it and then we
have chicken
maximus which sounds like a roman
emperor who is also a coward
they have chicken sausage chicken tikka
just a lot of chicken just a lot of
chicken that's that's what this has like
oh my god can i just weigh this it feels
like a a small baby i'm holding a small
baby
504 grams for a medium pizza and finally
we have what appears to be the king of
all of these chicken lover pizzas it's
an indo
fusion
max
it sounds like i don't know some sort of
detergent but uh dude you can't even
tell what like what number of
ingredients is on this
i can't even see the pizza at this point
oh my god
i feel like a new man you have to order
this once in your life it gives me deep
displeasure to announce that domino's
india has decided to create
these monstrosities called pizza burgers
is a burger supposed to make this noise
in bangalore where i'm from if
something bad happens to you your friend
will say you got a bun
and this is the one they're talking
about
they have three flavors classic veg
premium veg and classic non-veg
oh
man
no
it's just veggies and so is that cheese
no
no no no no
you know what i thought this would be
bad
and
it's worse
it's much worse it's not a burger like
nothing about this is a burger except
for the bun this might be the worst
thing i've eaten on food water so far
okay
we did kind of the same thing only we
call them sandwiches i've never gotten
one of these outside of food wars i'm
just gonna pick this one right here it
looks like it is a chicken habanero you
wanna ever wanna get bummed out no
philly cheesesteak listen up
philadelphia domino's wants to make you
guys proud
philadelphia why are you not rioting
right now and the domino's headquarters
whatever it is because this is just
insulting oh no remember the
mediterranean veggie here it is in
sandwich form also has banana peppers on
it oh here we go
chicken
bacon
ranch
love that combination oh no you look at
this
look at this this is just too much
this one i just labeled sandwich i
didn't know which one it was what the
[ __ ] look at this what is this
is this a buffalo chicken no on this one
guys buffalo
let us know in the chat how insulted you
are by this both residents of buffalo
and buffalo the animals
uh italian
they didn't skip by the pepperoni gotta
give him credit for that one the chicken
parm sandwich
[Music]
surprisingly bland
they're not terrible but i mean why get
this instead of pizza
continuing the list of exclusive
abominations we have a string of pastas
but also pasta pizzas which look um
fascinating here in domino's india we
use fusilli pasta fusilli being the
whole helix dna strand of pastas we have
creamy tomato wedge non-veg and we have
moroccan spice wedge and non-veg and to
accompany these
i'm sure delicious pastas we have pasta
pizzas in the same flavors wow just
really inventive stuff going on over
here this is the moroccan spice
vegetarian pasta pizza
here we go they ask you how you are you
just have to say that you're fine when
you're not really fine
[Music]
it sent a shiver down my spine it's so
bad
how many different types of carbs are in
this my disappointment is immeasurable
and my day is ruined okay i'm gonna try
one pasta
just in case it's good let's mix it up
this one has some tomato sauce in it
this is bad we here in the us have our
pasta options that come in penny noodles
these type of noodle guys is that a good
shot of a penny noodle you can get it in
pasta primavera chicken carbonara
chicken alfredo italian sausage marinara
again i'm not i don't know why you're
getting pasta a pizza place
i like it just fine
is this the best pasta you can get in
your neighborhood most certainly not now
on to chicken wings we have three
flavors tomato chili sauce
peri peri and boneless berry perry i'm
gonna try the peri-peri wings just to
see
how they stack up
they're all right this is your standard
run-of-the-mill chicken wings in a
country filled with millions of flavors
i can't believe we're still doing these
same standard flavors like peri peri
barbecue and ranch where is my chicken
65 my chicken moliga pudi my chicken
ghee roast oh chicken girls dominoes if
you do chicken ghiro's wings i think
you're going to get a lot more people
wings in the u.s we got them too here's
three flavors that we have here in the
u.s honey barbecue sweet mango habanero
and garlic parmesan dominos if you're
watching you need to effective
immediately stop
doing this i don't know who in your
organization said you know what we
should do instead of tossing it in the
sauce you know how everyone expects
their wings to come we'll just put on
here and drizzle look at this look at
this mess toss it toss the wings toss in
the sauce toss it in the sauce that's
how everyone does this how's supposed to
be done
next up exclusive sides number one
cheese pops
tater tots as you call them we have
fries and they're crinkle cut that's
unique not a lot of restaurants here in
india do this they have been flavored
with a bunch of stuff though so i think
they've used their
oregano and chili flakes over here they
have here a veg parcel it's like a
little puff with the same you know
paneer pieces over here
then they have
what they call
tacos there's a vegetarian version with
some
simple veg cutlets
and they have a non-vegetarian version
with
a slab of chicken i do not expect that i
am speechless at the level of quality
these sides have compared to the pizzas
then you have a chicken parcel and
finally they have
little meatballs of chicken with
peri-peri dust on top of them this is
literally just one of their
pizza toppings that they're selling as a
side
yes
india has breadsticks and stuffy cheesy
bread but they don't have garlic ones
but we got those we also have these
parmesan
twists
look at these twisty guys and for
stuffed cheesy bread you can get it as
spinach and feta or bacon and jalapeno
dips this i don't know what they just
were like how can we give people pizza
without bread behold
this
it is a dish
of cheese and marinara sauce they're
calling them dips cheesy marinara
and the five cheese come on look at that
look at that oil you see that right
there
exclusive sauces at the us dominoes you
know what that means
sauce tall
here you can get these exclusive sauces
in the u.s can't get them in india we
got hot buffalo
sweet mango habanero honey barbecue
ranch
ooh blue cheese
for the wings right and
garlic
yeah it says ranch they gave us two
ranches instead of a ranch and a garlic
and marinara they're like generous in
the marinara that's a big one
we have two separate dips over here in
domino's india we have a cheesy dip and
we have a cheesy
jalapeno
dip cheesy dip
ooh
oh that tastes good okay cheesy jalapeno
dip really yum
something about this tastes spoiled is
this pasta's expiry date it feels like
curdled milk go with the cheesy jalapeno
dip for sure it's time for desserts
dessert
we just have one dessert here in
domino's india but it's a banger this is
a choco lava cake you heat it up and
boom
gooey
lava
goodness
oh wow
this fixed everything that was wrong
with the menu of dominoes up until now
just eating this is so comforting i can
feel those memories
of the pasta and the burger and that
ridiculousness that they served slowly
disappearing from my head like like
thoughts from dumbledore's head when
he's near the pencil
hey india check out these desserts we
got you can't have them uh over here we
have a marbled cookie brownie and go for
brownie right
[Music]
what the hell dude these are great oh my
god
it's cookie dough and brownie what a
great idea
miss tips i don't know who i don't know
who in your organization
said let's do dips but you need to let
that person go
it's like chunky applesauce
and
cinnamon twists
now it's time for drinks yet again it's
pepsico winning over here we have pepsi
we have 7up and mirinda
unlike a lot of other restaurants
domino's is yet to switch from plastic
pet bottles to something like cans or
reusable
cups
drinks you get in the us can't get in
india and said the uk jesus i'm cracking
up
coke
diet coke
fanta orange
the doctor
sprite
dasani water i'm taking the dr pepper
time for calories our large hand toss
margarita pizza has
256.4 calories per slice so that means
the full pizza is
2051.5 calories which is over twice your
daily recommended protein intake and
172.5 percent your daily sodium intake
our large cheese pizza is 2
240 calories that's a 9.19
increase from india's cheese pizza look
i screwed up i needed a thin crust for
the crust section
of this video and i just randomly made
it this large
just understand that
maybe
victoria can you do me a favor and take
this pizza here and just like put it
right there like can you just do that in
post please
next up one slice of a large deluxe veg
pizza is 220.5
calories and so the entire pizza is
1764 calories this is our large pacific
veggie veggie pizza and it is 310
calories per slice which makes the full
pizza
2
480 calories that's a 40
calorie increase in the us and oof
get a load of that sodium over 200
percent your daily amount at domino's
india our highest calorific pizza is the
chicken dominatrix
chicken dominator the chicken dominator
dominating the calories i guess one
slice will cost you 399 calories and the
entire pizza is a whopping
3192 calories which is
159.6 of your recommended daily intake
please
steer clear from eating an entire
chicken dominator
our us dominance pizza with most
calories is this the cali chicken bacon
ranch one xl brooklyn slice of this it's
560 calories that makes the full pie 3
360 calories that's 168 percent your
daily recommended calorie amount it's
worth it it's delicious go get a slice
tell him joe from food worth sent to you
they'll have no idea what you're talking
about all right thank you domino's india
that was delicious um god bless me for
eating all of that but god bless you for
continuing to make some of india's
favorite pizzas i am questioning the
whole pasta and burger thing though
and i hope you do too